on Wednesday morning the world awoke to
news of a secret operation carried out
by the Islamic Revolutionary Guards from
a launch site in Iran's central desert
it successfully used a two-stage rocket
but its first military satellite in
space the newer or light is now 425
kilometers above us orbiting earth the
head of the Revolutionary Guards says it
gives Iran's military new strategic
advantages we'll turn up the volume it
is a necessity for such powerful defense
forces like the Revolutionary Guard to
have access to advanced capabilities
today the powerful armies of the world
have no comprehensive defense plan if
they don't have a place in space today
we can monitor the world from space and
means boosting strategic data for the
IRGC putting the satellite into orbit
gives us a technological advantage and
is also a powerful asset in the
intelligence ron has put satellites in
space before but the success of the new
earth comes after several failures in
recent years it's expected to be used
for intelligence gathering secure
military communications navigation and
reconnaissance whatever leaders need to
support from the sky Iran's military
assets on earth and the satellite isn't
the days only technological development
the difference between this satellite in
previous ones is that its propulsion
uses a combined solid and liquid fuel
only a few superpowers have this
capability only a few countries the rest
are consumers of this technology it's a
proud moment for Iran's Revolutionary
Guards the group suffered a major
setback to its reputation after the
accidental shoot down in January of
Ukraine International Airlines flight 75
to all 176 people on board were killed
since the beginning of the 21st century
Iran despite diplomatic and economic
isolation has managed to develop the
technology necessary to elbow its way
into an elite club along with rivals
like the United States and Israel as
well as allies like Russia China India
Iran is one of only a dozen countries in
the world
with the homegrown rocket technology to
launch its own satellites into space
Zane bus Ravi aljazeera Tehran let's go
over to our White House correspondent
Kimberly how kid let's start first of
all Kimberly with the the u.s.
president's threat to start shooting at
Iranian boats what is the US Navy saying
about that will they now escalate any
difficult situations straight to the use
of deadly force well we're watching for
that very carefully we know that there
will be some podium briefings by both
the State Department and the Department
of Defense in the next hour and we are
monitoring that but here at the White
House that things have been a little bit
quiet in terms of information but that
doesn't seem to be the case necessarily
behind the scenes in fact we spotted the
Director of National Intelligence
Richard Grinnell he was walking in the
driveway behind me went into the West
Wing we can only presume that there are
some meetings going on where this is a
topic of discussion but again none of
this has been confirmed from the White
House
the only messaging we've had so far is
from the US president on Twitter here is
what he had to say I have instructed the
United States Navy to shoot down and
destroy any and all Iranian gunboats if
they harass our ships at sea and this is
something that has been escalating in
terms of tensions in recent weeks the
United States accusing Iran of while
they were while the US was conducting a
drill off of Kuwait in the Persian Gulf
they alleged that Iran's fast boats came
very close to the u.s. Navy ship that in
fact at one point they pointed a machine
gun the u.s. taking this very seriously
and as a result now with the reports of
this military satellite launched into
orbit the US president sending this very
stern tweet Kimberly as we're talking
right now I've just heard that the that
Mike Pompeo has been saying the US will
hold Iran accountable for the satellite
launch the question is how
and that is a very big question because
the US president had believed that he
had got sort of to a place of military
deterrence he remember those escalations
months ago that ratcheting up following
the drone killing of general Soleimani
the US had felt that at that point
things had settled down but there has
been increasing escalation not only the
reports of the sort of the activity in
the Persian Gulf but also the reports of
u.s. vulnerability something that was a
major concern for the United States in
terms of that aircraft carrier off of
Guam and of course had been hit hard by
coronavirus much of their crew
experiencing an outbreak even a death as
a result of the outbreak on that
aircraft carrier so the question becomes
whether Iran has seen this as a
potential ability to expose or rather
take advantage of a vulnerability of
course the United States very hard hit
by coronavirus and grappling with that
and what's become clearer is in the
midst of all of this even in the midst
of a pandemic these military rivalries
are continuing and Kimberly there's a
question about immigration right now
given the US president's latest tweet so
has that stopped well no in fact the US
president is set to sign this order he
is very clear about it in fact he
tweeted saying that he will be signing
this order today but there's some
confusion about the explanation as to
why the US president argues that this is
because he wants to protect American
jobs and there's no question tens of
millions of Americans have lost their
jobs the lineups for the food banks
right now are historic but at the same
time the president's only stopped or put
a pause for 60 days on those who want to
become permanent residents or citizens
he says he doesn't want to overwhelm not
just jobs but also the the medical
resources as the United States fights
this pandemic but what hasn't been
stopped are some of
the visas for farmworkers or visas for
some of the more highly skilled workers
so it begs the question of the US
president is really trying to protect
American jobs
why didn't he do it across the board
halt it doesn't seem to be consistent
and lends credibility to the Democratic
criticism that in fact the US president
is trying to take advantage of
delivering on a campaign promise in an
election year and there's no question as
the US president tweeted that he would
be signing this immigration order today
that in fact he also mentioned the fact
that he has kept another campaign
promise that is building along the
southern border of the United States and
Mexico that wall that he promised to
deliver so this is an election year were
months away from an election the US
president insists this is about
protecting American jobs American public
health but many are questioning those
motivations all right thanks so much
Kimberly how get back